[Musique]
ils rêvent d'en faire la capitale de
safran sas aux
[Applaudissements]
marseille à plat si jean luc mélenchon
en tête lors du premier tour de la
présidentielle
dans la foulée la ville lui a offert son
costume de député
pourtant même ici
[Musique]
auréolé du titre de premier opposant
ils peinent à mobiliser la rue contre la
politique du gouvernement
monsieur melançon bonjour vous êtes
content
j'suis là pourquoi
on est passés unis selon vous dans la
contestation aujourd'hui c'est pas une a
perdu 2 c'est qu'il faut faire joindre
l'ensemble des forces syndicales
politiques associatives entre on va pas
aller comme ça se faire déchiqueter au
détail près bon enfin je parle
nous sommes en novembre dernier il n'a
rien perdu de sa popularité
ni de sa capacité à passer en un instant
du sourire à l'intimidation
est ce qu'il n'est pas trop tard
monsieur mélenchon ce n'est pas trop
tard mais monsieur dans la ville est
jamais trop tard jusqu'à la dernière
seconde est la dernière
surtout si la question lui déplaît
et alors vous
allez j'allais la commune
alors quel est son vrai visage
au-delà de ces coups de boutoir contre
les journalistes nous avons passé
plusieurs semaines sur la piste d'un
homme politique insaisissable
charismatique et charmant autour de ces
militants ne me rappelle plus vous
qu'est ce que vous faites ce
que vous voyez spécial chez les sauvages
nous nous sommes glissés dans les
coulisses du mouvement qu'il construit
sur les ruines du socialisme
[Musique]
et ils ne font pas un machin deux
arrivées de stars
pas au psg
comment l'ancien apparatchik du ps est
il devenu seul m à gauche
[Musique]
nationale
internationaliste et souverainistes à la
fois
séducteur et colérique
les différents mélenchon forme d'un
puzzle énigmatique
malgré ces rapports houleux avec les
médias il a fini par accepter notre
caméra on se met là
pour se livrer comme rarement auparavant
en tant que je m'installe bien ouais
mélenchon selon jean-luc n'a pas
commencé l'espère
il compte déjà plusieurs vies plusieurs
identités et entame aujourd'hui une
énième réinvention nous sommes encore
bien fragile mes amis et nombreux sont
ceux qui aimeraient nous voir chuter
mais souvenez-vous à chaque instant que
c'est du monde entier qu on vous regarde
visionnaire ou aveuglé par son propre
destin à 66 ans jean luc mélenchon
repart en campagne pour une dernière
métamorphose
on
[Musique]
jean luc mélenchon c'est d'abord un
casse-tête pour biographe
un homme qui depuis sa naissance se
construit dans le mouvement permanent
vous êtes vous
[Musique]
un peu d'ici un peu de la barre de
partout et chaque fois que
on m'a jeté à la figure
les mots parachute et tout ça je lui ai
toujours mal vécue parce que j'ai eu
l'impression que recommencer la scène
initiale de tous ces pauvres pieds-noirs
jeter la même ça
[Musique]
cette scène initiale son premier
parachutage à marseille il l'a vécue
avec des milliers d'autres pieds noirs
qui comme lui débarqué du maroc
car jean luc mélenchon est né à tanger
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'en 1962 l'année de ses 11
ans qu'ils traversent la méditerranée
et découvre la france
pour s'installer à yvetot en normandie
donc on est remonté vers la normandie au
mois d'août c'est ce qui fait le piquant
de la chose c'est que au mois d'août à
tanger maroc ya plus une feuille verte
en tout est sec et la set quand pas écho
frier par la fenêtre du train tout était
vert des arbres partout des prairies
alors c'était très exotique quoi voilà
cette enfance il l'a brandi toujours
comme son vaccin contre le racisme j'ai
entendu des choses absurdes j'étais
gamin mais
alors bon moi j'étais le biko donc j'ai
une expérience personnelle de ce que
c'est que d'être ambitieux les uns biko
c'est comme ça qu'on parlait
alors de samassa m'a forgé si vous
voulez une identité universaliste qui et
qui fait que la chair de poule dès qu'il
est question de s'enfermer dans une
une communauté
histo vous descendez
dans ma jeunesse il est déjà descendu ça
va
sa jeunesse justement il en maîtrise -
le récit
car en quelques années jean luc
mélenchon a vécu plusieurs vies en une
c'était dans le jura
à lons le saunier la ville de rouge et
de l'hymne l'auteur de la marseillaise
on retrouve sa trace dans l'hebdomadaire
local
mais loin des pages politiques
lorsqu'il avait 25 ans jean luc
mélenchon était dessinateur de presse or
voilà là ce sont des archives il était
là dans les années 70 donc on doit
retrouver on doit retrouver en 1977 on
va retrouver normalement son travail
ils avaient une chronique qui arrivait
en fin de journal
et voilà c'était ses dessins là si on a
été plus exemplaires voilà c'était la
vie sont les branches la vie sur les
branches voilà c'était en der une petite
réflexion un peu philosophique sur
l'actualité c'est signé jean luc
mélenchon c'est signé moss et nos
voisins c'est signé sur ces thèmes aux
mais c'était lui qui fait et moselle et
moselle non sans blague limo les détails
impossible mon journal ne s'intéresse
pas au détail
c'est des petites choses
alors là c'est presque du sans paroles
mais c'est difficile de faire passer un
message dans du sang parole
on a deux cases où il se passe rien et
la troisième les tragédies des autres
sont toujours d'une banalité
désespérante
c'est bien vu plus étonnant pour un
homme qui s'attaquent si souvent aux
médias il signait aussi des articles
toujours sous pseudo jean louis muller
ce qui est amusant c'est que en fait
l'histoire dit qu'il voulait devenir
journaliste à la croix du jura qui n'a
pas été pris je sais pas pourquoi mais
quand on regarde ses dessins ce qui est
amusant c'est de se dire que s'il avait
été embauché il en a peut-être été
rédacteur en chef ou un auditeur du
journal et ça serait aujourd'hui un
tranquille notable de province plutôt
que d'être le leader de la france
soumise des fois ça tient à peu de
choses
à l'époque jean luc mélenchon se cherche
il cumule les identités moss le
caricaturiste jean-louis mula le
journaliste
mais aucun n'arrive a éclipsé sans terre
le militant trotskiste
[Musique]
quand j'étais journaliste
donc dans le jura mais mon nom était
connu comme celui d'un affreux
révolutionnaires gauchistes des années
68 alors ceux qui m'ont embauché monde
ibo bas ça serait bien si tu mettais un
autre nom alors me la mula après je m'en
vais faire des dessins pour la croix du
jura mais seulement vous figurer que
c'était beaucoup de courage de leur parc
de m'embaucher pour y faire des dessins
en plus des dessins pitoyable parce que
je sais pas où j'ai trouvé une idée
pareille mais c'était un dialogue entre
un corbeau et une oie blanche
rétrospectivement je me dis mais mais
comment ces braves gens acceptaient un
truc pareil moi me suis même pas rendu
compte de ce que je faisais mais je vous
avoue je n'avais jamais réfléchir au
cours de ma vie sous l'angle sous lequel
vous veulent présenter c'est à dire 2
c'est vrai que c'était plusieurs vies il
ya un proverbe africain qui dit on et il
ya plusieurs personnes dans la personne
est peut-être que tout l'enjeu
philosophique c'est d'arriver à mettre
ces personnes d'accord entre elles
les rares personnes qui ont connu tous
et mélenchon successives assister à ces
différentes métamorphose vivent encore
dans le jura
elle est close
gabriel amard son gendre et claude
buchot fontvieille ami vigneron
à lons il ya la même chose je
ne vois que la continuité dans le
parcours de l'insoumis en chef
sa conversion tardive à l'écologie par
exemple aurait germé ici il ya 40 ans
claude buchot pionnier du vin bio en
serait le principal artisan
journalistes entre guillemets il
il faisait de la pêche pour les journaux
de coin le progrès la voix du jura et
moi j'étais déjà dans le mouvement
social comme on dit les associations
l'agrobiologie ce qu'en fait claude
c'est le militant écologiste et des
croissants qui a fini de nous
qui a fini le travail si vous voulez moi
je vois bien depuis le début des années
90 avec jean luc mélenchon on écrit on
est signe des textes
sur le fait qu' on peut pas être dans
cette course folle quand au capitalisme
transnational au prix de détruire la
planète et ça a donné un caractère
concret au raisonnement politique
claude buchot à pousser l'engagement un
peu plus loin pendant la campagne
présidentielle il a sorti de ses fûts le
vin des insoumis
c'est cela voilà alors ça c'est l'aider
elle date de 2016 voyait donc il ya un
an et demi
ah oui et même le logo jean luc
mélenchon 2010 est là exactement cette
cuvée avait pour idée de créer un lien
social un lien entre les tous les
insoumis de france quoi
il en a vendu 5000 bouteilles à travers
le pays c'est lui qui en a eu
l'initiative tout seul et c'est ça qui
lui plaît dans un mouvement qui n'est
pas un parti comme les autres
quand vous êtes dans un parti politique
ce quelques pauvres t'aligner voilà et
savait que moi le mouvement ça me va
très bien on perd pas du temps à
préparer des élections les assemblées
générales etc au moins on se rend compte
on discute on bosse en bosse ou le
projet oui ça me plaît beaucoup plus
pas de partis pas de structure mais un
chef et des lieutenants ou des relais
dans le jura c'est son gendre gabriel
amard qui est aussi le gardien de
l'héritage mélenchoniens ben vous voyez
c'est c'est sa médaille de sénateurs de
95 ans quand il a été réélu sénateur en
95 j'avais dirigé cette campagne
sénatoriale je venais elle est élue
maire j'étais tout jeune maire de viry
châtillon essonne
pourquoi si vous qui l'avez
bas parce qu'à un moment donné il a
déménagé de massy pour aller à paris
puis il m'a confié de trois objets comme
ça
il a rencontré jean luc mélenchon en
1986 épouse et sa fille unique en 2016
le couple a tous les livres du leader en
double chacun le sien
[Musique]
ils sont venus casser ou pas
peut-être pas non peut-être foire ainsi
celui-ci les voiliers pour gabriel mon
camarade et mon fils
ah ouais bah on est tous un peu des fils
spirituels quand on milite avec jean luc
mélenchon parce que c'est un passeur il
veut nous faire la courte échelle donc
il a plein de fils
nous n'irons pas plus loin dans le
chapitre familiale chose rare en
politique les mélenchon ne s'expose
jamais c'est la vie privée
c'est un truc vraiment ce oui bah
écoutez notre vie c'est 90% du temps de
la politique de la vie associative
pour ce qui me concerne donc ouais y'a
besoin des fois de tirer le rideau et
c'est un sage
mais c'est aussi un militant de combat
donc il est au poste de combat que les
circonstances imposent
chef malgré lui vraiment jean luc
mélenchon laisse entendre régulièrement
qu'il pourrait abandonner la politique
se consacrer à la littérature
nous le retrouvons à marseille où le
nouveau député prend ses marques
là où d'autres font les marchés puis
visite surtout les musées les lieux de
culture
comme cette bibliothèque où nous l'avons
suivi plusieurs heures vu déambuler au
hasard ou s'extasier devant un manuscrit
de xvème siècle
vous avez holopherne rendez compte de ce
que c'est c'est ya autres entre lui et
nous y'a quoi six siècles tous parlent
tous dit quelque chose comment il avait
organisé la page ce qu'il représente
hélas le bâton car ce type
tout
dessiné vous aussi
on verra dans six siècles si on reste
quelque chose puis bon serait pas
d'intérêt tandis qu'à 6 en 1
mais son livre de chevet se trouve au
rayon science fiction et c'est peut-être
l'une des clés du personnage quoi ça a
expliqué notre
fondation d'isaac asimov
un empire un roman d'anticipation dans
lequel le héros est un intellectuel
capable de prévoir toutes les crises
politiques d'une civilisation et de
d'idées les hommes à travers les siècles
en leur apparaissant sous forme d'un
hologramme j'ai lu saver voire 20 ans
allez on va dire 25 et cette histoire du
gars qui apparaît en hologramme bon il
va vous faire un dessin weave j'ai
trouvé ça là dedans c'est de là que
vient le web le personnage dont vous
parlez c'est quelqu'un qui est très
cultivé qui s'intéressent à la chose
politique et qui apparaît en hologramme
est ce que c'est un modèle au
lycée vous avais bien sûr à l'époque où
je les lui c'était ma tentation de dôme
jeune je trouvais le marxisme peu sec
pack renonce pas le mot je trouvais trop
mécanique en tout cas tel comme
l'enseignait il y avait un côté tarder
toc toc 8 août tandis que dans le roman
d'asimov qu'elle donne ses îles et
anthropologues les sociologues donc il
prenait en compte tous les paramètres
humains et culturels donc ça me
fascinait jeu suivant mais ils se
trompent à la fin non c'est pas qu'ils
se trompent c'est non j'ai mal dit lâche
je vous raconterai pas l'histoire vous
accueillir le livre mais
il a commis le péché d'orgueil de tous
ceux qui croient avoir trouvé les clés
mais vous avez trouvé feront l'effort
et s'il était lui aussi victime de son
orgueil
alors je suis
allé aux
prisonniers de la vie de prophètes qui
l'endossent y est maintenant à paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les apparitions les métamorphoses de
jean-luc mélenchon
alain duhamel les observe depuis 30 ans
les deux hommes ont un point commun et
un seul avoir été des intimes de
françois mitterrand oui ils me diront
adoré passer en revue les les dirigeants
socialistes les espoirs socialiste
comparer les personnes et puis il a
prononcé le nom de jean-luc mélenchon
j'ai fait une petite grimace et il s'en
est aperçue et m'a dit mais non mais ne
le sous estime sûrement pas c'est
quelqu'un qui est de bon niveau il est
cultivé et c'est un très bon orateur il
arrivera peut-être à quelque chose vous
verrez si son éloquence ne les livre pas
bon c'est ça mon premier souvenir de
mélenchon mais maintenant c'est autre
chose maintenant il se présente un peu
comme le prophète armé a armé de son
éloquence pas armés d'armes physique
mais je pense que dans sa tête ça sa
vraie vocation maintenant c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
prophète coup
l'accusation revient souvent car jean
luc mélenchon fascine ses admirateurs et
tient son auditoire en haleine comme peu
d'hommes politiques
plutôt à la façon d'un professeur
charismatique
c'est le dernier visage du jeune
mélenchon est notre dernière étape dans
le jura
caricaturiste journalistes avant de
basculer totalement dans la politique il
a aussi été enseignant dans ce lycée
technique
oh
ils avaient une vingtaine d'années ces
élèves à peine - pierre coton était l'un
d'eux
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a pris
cette photo de lui c'était ça c'est moi
cette rencontre fut la plus importante
de sa vie au regard des
[Musique]
loges des pions je suis désolé je
mélenchon j'avais peur
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui parle de
philo poésie à des élèves qui sortent du
technique avec une facilité comme ça
génial c'était génial pour nous pour
vous donner un exemple
pour vraiment
imaginer comment il pouvait être je
pense que vous connaissez le film le
cercle des poètes disparus
ben sur mélenchon c'était ça c'était
sans ces voix là il nous a jamais
demandé de nous mettre debout sur le
bureau on est bien d'accord il nous a
jamais demandé ça mais
peut-être qu'il nous l'aurait demandé je
sais pas peut-être que certains orienté
sur le bureau mais voilà
et comme en été en internat on le
retrouvait comme surveillant
pour surveiller les dortoirs on se
retrouvait pour certains dans sa chambre
autour de lui puis on discutait de tout
on parle de politique non
de plein de choses
il n'est pas militant de la france
insoumise mais fait partie de ce que
jean luc mélenchon a su toucher lors de
la présidentielle
c'est la première fois pour moi qu'il a
vraiment mis
l'homme qu'il est dans ses meetings mais
bien parce que si si vous suivez ses
meetings d'avant il était plus dans
l'agressivité il était plus là il était
un peu dans le rôle du professeur s'est
il est évident qu'il véhicule et un
programme facile et ouais je pense qu'il
est encore dans les cordes parce que
parce qu'il est depuis quelques temps il
y retourner dans ses travers on est bien
d'accord
[Musique]
les travers que regrette son ancien
élève son revenu en pleine lumière lors
de sa dernière prestation télévisuelle
des sorties piquante qui vire parfois la
colère jean luc mélenchon ça y est vous
avez fini il y en a un qui veut en
rajouter encore dans cinq minutes vous
êtes tous les deux par terre c'était
extrêmement pointues sur certains sujets
et beaucoup plus l'accident sur donnons
adame ba c'est la solution y avait je ne
suis pas laxistes et sur sont justifiées
on va peut-être retrouver lyon sont loin
d'être retrouvé le séjour italien elle
avait toujours et perds mon égard j'ai
toujours été marcher je vous connais on
se connaît depuis longtemps on a faim
ferrand que vous aviez notre reportage a
failli prendre fin ce jour là quand même
et puis l'autre mélenchon a accepté de
renouer le dialogue vous avez parlé
après trois semaines de silence
je ne demande pas qu'on approuve
et pourquoi tant de haine entre nous
avec les journalistes vous rendez pas
compte de ce que j'endure depuis dix ans
tout y est passé
ma maison ma famille
des caricatures abominable des choses
volontairement injurieuses de la part de
gens que je connaissais depuis longtemps
parfois la volonté de blesser de
jeu le jeune âge ne le pardonne pas
certain
et puis après je
je suis dégoûté par un système pareil
pourquoi vouloir blesser à quoi ça sert
vous diriez pas d'accord allez vous me
dévoiler multi money le bras la
planification de danse et de la folie
faut pas faire ça ok on n'est pas
d'accord quel besoin d'aller plus loin
et passer sur un terrain aussi violent
enfin bref
je pense qu'il a le sentiment d'être
beaucoup plus mal traités que les autres
alors que quand on se rappelle tout ce
qu'on a pu dire sur nicolas sarkozy sur
françois l'orne sur marine le pen je
veux dire qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'ils
soient maltraités par rapport aux autres
nettement mais lui dans sa tête si c'est
aussi parce que l'univers médiatique
pour lui est le bras armé de tout ce
qu'ils détestent dans la société c'est
le bras armé des dominants c'est le bras
armé de des possédants seller c'est le
bras armé des chefs de file économique
et cetera
socioculturel donc il ya ça et puis
vieillit comme il est tout sauf bête il
ya aussi le fait que un bon moyen d'être
populaire c'est de s'en prendre aux
journalistes il n'y a pas de la part de
jean luc mélenchon me semble-t-il un
goût à cette adversité
raquel garrido a été la porte parole de
jean luc mélenchon elle est encore son
avocate celle qui le défend coûte que
coûte dans les des têtes dures et puis
on assume l'affrontement des coups on en
donne des coups on en prend
mais au final on sait ce pas détourner
de nos objectifs c'est pas sa faiblesse
pour transformer l'essai est passé de
premier opposant à la loi
on parle de prendre le pouvoir suprême
dans la cinquième économie un cinquième
puissance du monde
on sait qu'un système c'est ce faire
mais l'adversité elle est colossal
colossal n'importe qui ayant subi ce cas
celui jean luc mélenchon aurait craqué
dix fois déjà dix fois donc cesser sa
force n'est pas seulement un atout c'est
même indispensable
mais il n'a pas toujours été l'homme de
la rupture jean luc mélenchon 36 ans le
plus jeune sénateur de france pendant 30
ans c'est un autre visage qu'à rebours
et jean luc mélenchon
militants socialistes discipline et
défendant l'union de la gauche à
l'opposé de sa stratégie actuelle si
maintenant la mode c'est de se maintenir
dès qu'on a 10 % des voix quoi qu'il
arrive il n'y aura plus un seul élu de
gauche dans ce pays
sénateurs ministres députés européens le
futur insoumis n'a eu aucun mal à se
fondre dans son environnement
vous avez un côté un peu caméléon aussi
vous avez eu différents différentes vies
dans votre vie politique dans ma vie
d'homme oui j'ai eu du goût à faire le
caméléon c'est à dire à être comme les
autres là où j'étais c'était pas très
dure en réalité un par contre
en politique je me reprocherais plutôt
plutôt d'avoir eu du mal à rompre quand
je savais qu'il fallait rompre au parti
socialiste où j'ai passé quand même
trente ans un l'essentiel de ma vie
politique est celle d'un socialiste très
convaincu de
trait je reste coi si vous voulez hein
mais j'ai eu du mal j'ai eu du mal à
rompre j'aurais dû si vous voulez dès
2005 quand il ya eu le référendum mais
vous êtes la partie non
en 2005 il ne quitte pas le ps mais fait
campagne contre le traité sur la
constitution européenne en rupture avec
la ligne de parti le nouveau melanson se
pose en boussole de la gauche le nom
rassemble à gauche est la leçon à
maintenant
alors il rassemble et les joyeux et il
est impertinent
et pour l'instant nous avons le vent
les figures de l'extrême gauche
l'accueillent à bras ouverts olivier
besancenot josé bové marie george buffet
seront bientôt dans son ombre ses
partenaires se sont beaucoup trompé sur
lui
ils ont cru que c'était simplement un
orateur exceptionnel mais un individu
isolé et en fait je pense que c'est
également un stratège il est arrivé à
dévorer le parti socialiste il est
arrivé à dévorer les écologistes et
parti communiste
versez un anthropophage en politique il
a dévoré tous ses alliés
en 2008 il claque la porte du ps
beaucoup y voient un suicide politique
rares sont ceux qui le suivent dans son
nouveau parti de gauche
la rupture est totale y compris avec ses
amis les plus proches
jérôme guedj était jusque là son bras
droit au parti socialiste et son fils
spirituel vers 15 16 ans j'ai rencontré
jean luc et puis là je pense déceler mon
intérêt pour la chose publique pour la
politique pour l'engagement à gauche et
puis donc on s'est plus quittés à partir
de ce moment là et j'avoue que ça a été
un informateur formidable et puis après
on est devenus on est devenu amis
jusqu'à une rupture qui a d'abord été
une vraie rupture politique parce que
pour jean luc mélenchon à un moment
donné si on n'est pas avec lui s'il ya
un peu de doutes qui apparaît alors on
est contre lui notre quelque vingt
années de compagnonnage et d'amitié se
sont fracassés sur cette séparation ce
schisme de choix qui a été fait à ce
moment là est-ce que selon vous c'est
lui qui a été le fossoyeur du parti
socialiste la première responsabilité
des difficultés du parti socialiste
c'est le parti socialiste que même moi
j'estime voilà que la grande erreur à un
moment donné du parti socialiste quand
on a un talent en son sein comme jean
luc mélenchon s'est pas faire en sorte
de le garder
jean luc mélenchon refuse l'évolution
socio libérale du parti socialiste
mais son départ c'est aussi sa rupture
avec un autre ancien ami françois
hollande nous avons connu un moment un
débat une controverse sur la question du
traité consuel il faut la dépasser il
faut savoir maintenant se rassemblent et
je pense être avec la future majorité du
parti socialiste celui qui peut
rassembler les socialistes
je lui en veux beaucoup
pas
pas seulement
d'avoir été aussi peu socialiste que l'a
été le président hollande c'est à dire
et fini son mandat y reste rien je ne
vais pas vous citer quelque chose pour
jos par des 35 heures là évidemment vous
ready c'est dans votre fauteuil vous
c'est du pur il ya du contre la
polémique continue peu réfléchi c'est le
café hollande rien
tout de travers et puis à la fin ont
tous passé par dessus bord la politique
de l'offre à la place de la politique de
la demande en 11 jours comme ça et face
à la télé et il annuler 150 ans
d'histoire de gauche avec un trait de
crayon
et donc ma rancoeur contre lui n'est pas
sur ce qu'il aurait dû faire un peu plus
comme ci ou un peu moins comme là c'est
de fonds il a détruit le mouvement
socialiste en france
et c'est un nouveau mouvement qu'il
prétend lui construire
pas simplement un parti une lame de fond
quitte à ne pas tout contrôler et
à la convention de la france un soumise
à clermont ferrand la moitié des
militants invités étaient tirés au sort
[Musique]
on n'est pas un parti on est un
mouvement on n'est surtout pas un parti
ou un mouvement ça ressemble quand même
qu de plus de gens c'est beaucoup plus
ouvert car partie c'est pour ça que je
préfère que ça reste en mouvement c'est
très ouvert mais il ya un truc dont on
discute pas ouais c'est le leader alors
y'a pas de leader y'a pas il n'y a pas
véritablement la vie vers la france ont
soumis ce bail à jean-luc évidemment
parce qu'il s'est présenté comme
président on va pas là mais c'est pas
notre gourou c'est pas notre sens et lui
lui-même l'expliquent qui veut passer
tout ce qui c'est le transmettre aux
jeunes qui arrivent derrière
le leader s'est mise en retrait
pour le chercher en vain dans les amis
ils préfèrent les coulisses
dans sa loge on retrouve l'ancien
professeur entouré de sa très jeune
garde
jean luc mélenchon a toujours su capter
leur attention
désormais ils leur donnent aussi leur
petite part de lumière et manon l'époque
de quoi déjà
plutôt que de prendre la tête d'un parti
il se place au coeur d'un mouvement un
élan de contestation qui promet des
ruptures radicales il faut sortir du
carcan il faut briser les chaînes il
faut sortir des traités budgétaire
européen qu'on préparait est signée
sarkozy est ensuite hollande parce que
c'est ça qui pousse le continent entier
à la misère et à la guerre il est donc
temps de tourner la page c'est ça que
nous ferons car il y aura une liste
europe 1 soumise aux élections
européennes
le pari d'une gauche de rupture dans le
rapport de force avec l'europe a déjà
été tentée
en grèce
c'est notre dernière étape
ici le cousin grecs des insoumis syriza
a pris le pouvoir sur un programme
mélenchoniens mais une fois aux
commandes ces dirigeants ont dû mener
une politique d'austérité hausse de la
tva allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite le mouvement s'est déchiré
un micro partis grecs rassemblant les
plus radicaux invité jean luc mélenchon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez bien
ces zones sinistrées la ganache 1
là il faut reconstruire après avoir été
détruit
si vous voulez dans ce qu'il ya de plus
de plus important la confiance que
ça c'est très dur ici c'est très dur
mais un temps si on lâche le terrain se
finit donc me v'là les insoumis d'hier
semblent résignés aujourd'hui et la
contagion menace je suis venu avec mes
amis pour vous remonter le moral
comme nous avons vu une fois la lumière
nous voudrions qu'elle brille toujours
tenez bon
ménage et à
l'échec du modèle grec il le sait est
aussi un signal inquiétant pour son
propre projet
le soir autour des quelques insoumis
français d'athènes l'homme aux mille
visages en arbore un que nous ne lui
connaissions pas
celui du chef qui doute
sa france insoumise at elle un avenir
charteau dans six mois le mouvement sera
un horrible champclos de querelles et de
lutte et franchement il faut accepter
avec patience l'idée que nous ne savons
pas ce comment cette structure va se
mettre en place et si lé diable est ce
que vraiment le 21e siècle celui du
peuple il va engendrer une organisation
de type tour ou pas le seul intérêt de
le savoir
[Musique]
avant de quitter la grèce éternelle le
chef de la france insoumise s'est rendu
sur l'acropole
[Musique]
jean luc mélenchon se cherche encore un
second souffle
on le dit parfois fatigué démoralisés
ça les énerve et la muse à la fois
lui seul écrire à la fin de l'histoire
en ancien journaliste il voudrait
presque le faire pour nous
ouais
entouré de ses amis
et suicidaire
c'est ça la narration en ce moment bon
je sais pas c'est ce qu'on a vu ce matin
j'étais aussi
c'est bien
sa défense
sur l apprenti remis d'un commis à lot
la pente est rude et l'avenir incertain
le tribun a essoufflé mais pas encore à
bout de souffle
seul rescapé d'une génération politique
entière balayé par un renouvellement
sans précédent
jean luc mélenchon est toujours à la
recherche d'un rôle à sa mesure
fossoyeur le sauveur de la gauche
là où d'autres voient un champ de ruines
lui prétend jeter les bases d'une
nouvelle fondation
[Musique]